27 años después la bbc pagará una
indemnización a la antigua niñera de los
príncipes william y harry
alexandra pettyfer que apareció este
jueves en la corte suprema de londres
había lanzado una acción judicial contra
el grupo audiovisual por los falsos
rumores que difundió la cadena
atribuyéndole una aventura con el
príncipe carlos la bbc ha acordado pagar
una indemnización sustancial a la señora
pettyfer y me gustaría aprovechar esta
oportunidad para pedir disculpas
públicamente a ella al príncipe de gales
y a los duques de cambridge y seis ex
por la forma en que la princesa diana
fue engañada y el posterior impacto en
todas sus vidas según una investigación
independiente el periodista martin
bashir habría engañado a la princesa
diana- mostrándole entre otras cosas un
falso recibo de aborto para hacerle
creer que su esposo tenía una aventura
con la niñera de sus dos hijos y rumores
que hubieran llevado llama a aceptar la
memorable entrevista en la cual
reconoció tener una relación
extramatrimonial la entrevista fue vista
por 23 millones de
y marcó el final público del matrimonio
real con fuertes repercusiones para la
vida de alexandra pettyfer y de diana
quien semanas después se divorció de
carlos si hubiéramos hecho bien nuestro
trabajo la princesa diana- habría sabido
la verdad en vida la decepcionamos a
ella a la familia real ya nuestro
público la bebé se anunció que el
programa nunca se volverá a emitir y
puso fin a la serie de mentiras y
escándalos que rodearon la famosa
entrevista